[Musique]
derudder 24,60 hors série dinan gilbert
est né en beauce et baigne dans la
musique depuis qu'elle est toute petite
semaine vraiment une affaire de famille
à 35 ans elle a déjà été chef assistante
de maestro kent nagano d'orchestre
symphonique de montréal pendant trois
ans et maintenant elle est chef et
directrice musicale de deux orchestres
au canada l'orchestré symphonique de
l'estuaire à rimouski et le camp loupe
symphony orchestra en colombie
britannique
mais elle est aussi chef attitré des
grands ballets canadiens alors elle
dirige pendant le temps des fêtes toutes
les représentations de casse noisette
voici paroles et musique avec dj terre
[Musique]
on
obama
[Musique]
dina gibert bonsoir et bienvenue à 24,60
on vous voit dirigé casse noisette vous
êtes chef attitré de leurs pièces des
grands ballets en plus diriger leurs
pièces de l'estuaire symphonique de
l'estuaire c'est à rimouski pas l'autre
bout du pays à kamloops donc pas
vraiment de frontières pour vous mais
cette passion de la vie parce que vous
avez 35 ans
c'est un parcours professionnel
absolument impressionnant wallon veulent
suivre au cours de cette de cette
dernière ou la passion de la musique
cette piqûre vous l'avez eu enfin déjà
trois oui très tôt parce que je suis la
cinquième d'une famille de six filles
donc à la maison j'étais toujours en
train d'entendre l'histoire pratiques et
l'horreur de piano on faisait aussi
partie de différents coeurs donc la
musique a toujours fait partie ma vie
lorsque votre vie à l'école aussi vous
avez voulu poursuivre la formation dès
le secondaire ou quoi rester présent
l'école en fait le piano est un
instrument qui est un peu imposé la
maison donc j'avais du plaisir oui mais
reste que comme n'importe quel enfant
qui qui se fait demander quelque chose
par ses parents quand j'ai découvert la
clarinette c'est un instrument que j'ai
choisi
d'autant plus aimé cet instrument est ce
à ce moment là que je me suis rendu
compte que il y avait quelque chose
d'autre avec la musique que je pouvais
explorées par le fait de pouvoir jouer
en groupe et c'est ce que jamais
davantage avec la fenêtre et je comptais
plus minutes de ma pratique parce que ce
n'est pas un instrument qui est un
produit sont peu de dire je pense que
c'est en choisissant c'est la claire
nette que tout le répertoire tout toutes
les mesures toutes les dames en fait
toutes les possibilités de pouvoir jouer
en groupe ça c'est une verte à moi
c'était très important parce que le
piano si ça peut être assez solitaire
oui vous allez vous êtes accompagné
parfois par des orchestres jouent seuls
c'est ça c'est ce qu'on fait dans ce que
j'avais comme carrière jusqu'à 16 ans en
tant que pianiste vous souhaitez
vraiment un travail solitaire tandis que
l'internet c'est sûr de pouvoir faire
différentes sur de musique de la musique
jazz avant la musique classique de faire
de l'harmonie d'orchestre
je trouve qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
possibilités que s'ouvraient à moi et ça
m'intéressait beaucoup c'est aussi en
faisant naître et renaître que j'ai
commencé à voir le métier de chef
d'orchestre en étant dirigé justement
par différentes avec un sourire lorsque
la vous et deux en bronze fait votre
corps secondaire la bonne il faut faire
un choix de carrière à ces jeunes vous
sortir de là bas au souci pour pouvoir
avoir accès à l'université
comment ça c'est fait ce choix là
comment vous l'avez fait en fait j'avais
aucune idée que je deviendrais un jour
chef d'orchestre parce que papa doc et
symphonique en bronze donc moi j'ai fait
mais mon cheminement musique avec le
plaisir avec le fait que j'ai eu des
belles rencontres des espèces
d'opportunités a dirigé à ses taux de
façon autodidacte je dirige un petit
choeur d'enfants se diriger dans les
cadets aussi c'est seulement quand j'ai
fait mon baccalauréat en clair et net
qui est en cours optionnels en direction
d'orchestre avec le chef paolo bellomia
et c'est lui qui après quelques cours
m'a rencontrée à pointe claire sont
maudits dealers qui tu avais déjà pensé
le chef d'orchestre
tu as vraiment les bonnes aptitudes pour
soit une bonne oreille et une facilité à
t'exprimer avec des mains et tout est ce
que tu avais pensé à ça mais l'idée de
diriger un orchestre pour moi c'était
le rêve ultime parce que je trouve qu'on
est un peu rassembleur autres avec une
multitude des experts dans leur
instrument ça aborde toutes les côtes et
de la musique est aussi en même temps on
est un contact privilégié bustin loose
avec le public en fait il faut sortir
pour une très bonne oreille donc la
capacité à entendre chaque son chaque
timbre en tout temps parce qu'en
répétition on doit corriger chaque chose
qui n'est pas exactement juste qu'ils
seraient pas jouer au bon moment au bon
endroit et tout donc sa demande si sa
demande bien entendu de leadership parce
que c'est on doit inspirer les gens des
joints de les gens doivent le suivre
mais c'est à nous de les convaincre que
la façon dont on va diriger l'oeuvre
dont on voit interpréter le de
tchaïkovski sera la bonne pour pour sa
console parce qu'on vient de voir donc
un peu près temps car son âge est moche
en tout genre famagouste parenthèse
parce que je vous ai vu le faire une
autre occasion
c'est à quoi elle sert la baguette à
quoi ça sert un chef d'orchestre
on a beau aimer la musique sont la
connaît pas on sait pas trop
qu'est ce qui motive qu'est ce qui
inspire un chef d'orchestre qui est ce
que vous avez apporté leurs églises ont
apporté une bien sympa que ça c'est
vraiment un objet tout simple je
pourrais très bien aussi dirigé avec mes
mains la raison pour laquelle on utilise
le béguin c'est tout simplement parce
que ça est beaucoup plus visible quand
on a grand nombre de musiciens devant
nous et on va la prendre de notre main
pour que ce soit une extension de notre
bras et ça fait en sorte que avec un
simple geste
j'ai beaucoup plus d'amplitude donc ça
lui beaucoup plus visible et comme chef
d'orchestre c'est hyper important dans
mon travail est de commencer par une
préparation donc donné l'inspiration
dans tous les sens du terme qui ont
inspiré les musiques puisse savoir à
quel moment on va débuter la musique
donc on fait une préparation une
inspiration et quand je vais tomber je
savais indiqué le premier temps et le
joueur différentes métriques le geste
l'ex à deux temps une musique qui
prêtent à trois temps une musique qui
prêtent à quatre temps et ça c'est
vraiment la technique d'organes vous en
la vendant chaque coup de baguette un
langage et son enfant on édite le tempo
mais à travers le tempo d'un d'un temps
à l'autre on va pouvoir illustrer un peu
le relief de la musique qu'est ce que la
musique est très dense où elle est
plutôt très légère donc multitude
d'informations qu'on communique donc de
décote de base une codification devant
ce que nous observons très très bien
comprendre c'est pour ça aussi que je
vais pour exercer mon métier
dans différents pays sans aucun problème
donc c'est très intuitif
c'est votre inspiration enfin vous
inspirer les musiciens avec la baguette
mais vous êtes sûr mais aussi le
leadership une certaine autorité avec la
baguette vous amener les musiciens là où
vous voulez d amener dans le sondage
tout à fait pis pour ceux qui on doit
avoir une comme à 6 4 l'argentin est une
des choses que je dis par exemple si le
fait que l'information des tout à coup
au bout le plus près du but c'est
possible donc si j'avais une gestuelle
qui était moi ton pour rien à ce
moment-là voir différentes informations
différents endroits donc on veut plutôt
qu'un analyser l'information pour que
tout soit clair et très intuitive pour
les musiciens
donc on se rassure on peut encore aider
parce qu'on veut tellement avoir absorbé
la musique qu'on veut tellement de
l'avoir en soi que si cette façon le
compense pas du tout la technique qui
ont fait seulement illustré cette
musique là j'ai en même temps faire un
doctorat parce qu'on n'est pas assez
vite sur le cégep le bac dont vous
découvrez la possibilité de la maîtrise
la direction sur ces classiques et
presque 12 ans d'études quand on
additionne tout seul au monde et je n'ai
pas compté mais le plaisir mais j'ai
fait une maîtrise et un doctorat en
direction d'orchestre
en effet avec paolo bellomia jean france
est arrivé à l'université de montréal
mais qu'est ce que le métier on la prend
à tous les jours il ya quelque chose à
prendre donc à chaque fois je mets les
piles sur le podium
j'apprends un nouveau répertoire exemple
de ce que vous apprenez encore de ce que
vous avez en direction d'orchestre au
doctorat c'est un doctorat ces principes
en thèse de 600 pages j'imagine que vous
écrivez vous avez fait ça sur l'harmonie
entre la musique et les images
oui c'était sur la méthodologie des
techniques appliquées pour diriger une
projection concert donc j'étais
intéressé à qu'est ce qu'on pouvait
faire comme chef pour bien synchroniser
tout ce qui était projections concerts
un film
donc quand on doit accompagner un film
dans cet écossais après aussi ça m'a
aidé pour dire que j'ai aussi débat lire
des choses comme ça mais quand dans le
fond le chef n'a pas le contrôle absolu
dans un sens et doit être au service de
l'image de l'image
ouais donc je trouvais que c'était une
des choses qui m'ont aidé à peaufiner ma
technique parce que justement là on
oubliait de souplesse et le moins de
fric
alors arrive donc le dr et
je me suis laissé dire que pendant vos
études de doctorat vous avez travaillé à
la billetterie du western parce que je
me trompe ça nous amène son parti porte
à l'eosl
oui que jean françois dubé qui était
chef adjoint de maestro nagano
vous connaissez bien comme et doctorants
mais ça ouvre aussi la porte pour être
recruté comme chef adjointe de nagano
donc c'est en effet ça c'est spécial
parce que pendant mes études de maîtrise
doctorat j'ai travaillé à temps partiel
à la billetterie de la fm et un guide
davantage que j'avais c'est que j'avais
la possibilité d'aller voir plein
concert gratuitement et ça m'a permis
aussi de voir tout le répertoire qui
était jouée dans une année avec un
orchestre devant les solistes qui est
invitée de superbes de parler même au
téléphone avec les gens qui des fois son
curieux avant de venir à une première
prestation d'un orchestre seulement
comment comment je sais que je devrai
t'habiller est ce que je veux c'est être
con ça donc j'ai beaucoup apprécié cette
expérience et puis ça mais encore utile
je dis rien à mon rôle de directrice
musicale aujourd'hui d'être près du
public de comprendre quelles vont être
les
et
les attentes du public donc toutes ces
choses m'ont beaucoup aidé et quand je
ris musicale donc je mets mon chapeau de
chef je mets mon chapeau aussi de drôles
de marketing favori donc si je ne sais
dire en comble qu'on doit avoir
mais donc plusieurs années plus tard je
rentre à la maison symphonique pour
ensuite travailler comme chez fascinante
dont j'avoue que c'est un grand
privilège
c'est vraiment un grand rêve de pouvoir
revenir chez patiente de maestro kent
nagano
oui j'imagine parce que ce qu'on m'a
aussi dit c'est que vous travaillez la
billetterie y avait eu des auditions
dont l'avait trouvé personne à la
hauteur de ce job là de chefs attendent
le maestro nagano et là je pense que
jean-françois vous aviez travaillé un
peu pour louer c'est nous avait vus elle
l'avait vous connaissez et appréciez
vous exactement oui en fait si je ramène
beaucoup de chance de ce côté là parce
que comme avant les auditions j'avais
une opportunité travailler pour
remplacer le chef qui était assistant ce
moment là donc je travaille pendant deux
semaines pendant le temps des fêtes et
j'avais vu donc l'expérience d'être dans
la salle de pouvoir guider maestro
d'entendre l'orchestré dirigé aussi
d'orchestre dans les dents dans les
répétitions et quand j'ai eu l'apn de
maestro nagano qui m'offrait le poste en
disant que j'avais le bon profil pour
soi puisque dans le fond on croyait en
moi dans ce rôle là ça a été extrêmement
fabuleux c'est là qu'a commencé donc
trois magnifiques années avec l'ouest m
qu'est-ce que ça avait appris pendant
ces trois années de questi vous lorsque
j'ai appris tellement de chance parce
que c'est un orchestre incroyable des
musiciens fabuleux de voir aussi la
quantité des répertoires qui vont
apprendre dans une semaine donc je
dirais que tout ce que j'apprenais en
une semaine pour représenter presque une
session à l'université je doublais
qu'est ce que j'ai appris aussi c'est de
voir le travail extrêmement inspirant de
maastricht et nagano quelqu'un qui va
être exigeant mais qui va être exigeant
avec beaucoup de respect parce qu'il
connaît enfants jusqu'à une on peut
aller dans une oeuvre icaunais d'enfants
de confiance à six musiciens puis à une
vision très claire de ce qu'est ce qu'il
veut faire avec chacune des oeuvres
oui il applique les critères de la
confiance le respect tout à fait l'essai
et
vision que de la musique que vous avez
développé grâce à cette expérience
l'expérience a été aussi de découvrir le
rôle jean directeur musical au sein
d'une communauté
je pense qu'on a avec la musique
classique on a un rôle à jouer dont on
peut avoir une vision sociale on peut
faire en sorte d'avoir un impact
bénéfique pour une population
je trouve que le semestre aucun tag
hanul vraiment beaucoup fait avec le fn
que ce soit en aidant ce qu'on puisse
avoir la maison symphonique
c'est un lieu magnifique une salle de
concert exceptionnel que ce soit et que
son programme la musique aux enfants qui
permet des jeunes de pouvoir avoir accès
à des cours de musique gratuitement
et ça c'est des choses qui m'ont
vraiment marqué que je transmets
maintenant dans mon rôle de directeur
musical à l'eau alors qu'elle se rendait
de l'estuaire et aux canaux symphony
orchestra
de mon côté je fais des ateliers dans
les écoles où je te contacte du jeune
public où ils peuvent enfin être en
contact avec un quatuor à cordes un
flûtiste carnettistes sympa sioniste et
voir des instruments qui aurait pas eu
l'opportunité de voir avant très très
avant votre et très longtemps on sera
brièvement à une pause
l'impact quelques minutes on se retrouve
tout c'était peu après 12h merci madame
je suis resté avec nous le temps doux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
gilbert à la direction cette fois ci de
leur caisse métropolitain avec des
élèves de la commission scolaire de
montréal la symphonie hochelaga qu'est
ce que ça représente de voir ces images
ne pouvant les enfants ont chanté en
choeur c'était très mais vraiment très
beau moment c'est avec quatre
compositeurs québécois qui avait donc
participent à ce projet là et de pouvoir
participer le goûtant d'élèves de voir
leur travail aussi que les enseignants
travers les clans s'est dit surpris
d'arriver à ce moment de présenter seul
devant leurs parrains et devant la
communauté sa mère très très
enrichissant j'avais une conception de
la musique je crois qui veut dire que la
musique c'est aussi du bien-être
oui c'est un bonheur de naître pourquoi
parce que c'est ce que ça apporte je
donne à ma vie moi c'est aussi le sait
autant le bien-être que peux me procurer
la musique mais aussi dépendamment de la
musique c'est un temps d'arrêt où je
trouve que nous vivons tellement vite
que pour moi quand je suis en train
d'écouter la musique ou encore quand
j'entraîne les dirigeants concert je
suis uniquement dans le moment présent
et j'ai un moment présent avec les
musiciens qui sont là à découvrir
accueillir tout ce qui se passe autour
puis je pense que c'est ce qu'on peut
savoir quand on vient écouter un concert
donc c'est un peu un bon pour un bon
pour le coeur un bon pour l'âme de
pouvoir apprécier en groupe avec avec la
personne qui vous accompagne un concert
et de vivre de belles émotions
vous appartenez avec vos 35 ans une
génération
est-ce que qui a peut-être plus éloigné
de la musique classique à ce que plus
difficile de rejoindre des jeunes de la
30ème de la vingtaine parce que on est
sollicité par toutes sortes d'autres
musiques je me dis que dans les
prochaines années
les gens de ma génération est d'autant
plus est intéressé par la musique
classique parce que là je pense qu'on
est vraiment un tournant majeur où on se
rend compte que tout va beaucoup trop
vite qu'on ait trouve sur steam il est
partout et je trouve que même quand je
vais voir des concerts et ses mots real
il ya de plus en plus de gens dans la
trentaine de même dans la vingtaine qui
vont voir soit l'opéra montréal les
grands vallée
les autres qu'est ce qu'on est
clairement rien donc juge pas trop
pessimiste par rapport à ça je trouve
que au contraire les orchestres ont de
plus en plus aussi en train de s'adapter
de trouver de nouvelles façons d'aller
chercher des publics
je pense par exemple à des ciné concerts
qui sont présentées je pense aussi à des
concerts qui sont plus dans un formule
de métissage de genres
par exemple aura la chance de diriger le
concert en avril prochain avec le groupe
français iam
donc soit on sentait que c'est des gens
de ma génération qui vont venir voir ce
concert 900 soldats temps vraiment
quelques heures seulement donc je pense
qu'il ya un engouement qui revient je
crois par rapport à la musique classique
même chose sur le jeu idiot
vous avez dirigé pour les jeux vidéo
need aussi même chose c'était vraiment
une découverte de voir que dans la salle
honnêtement c'est vraiment beaucoup plus
jeune que moi dans la salle
je trouve que c'est normal fonds ne
pouvons faire de sortir des cadres
habituels de la forme du concert qu'on
connaît avec ouverture concertos et
symphonies
je pense que quand on est celle qu'on
n'ouvre plus ce cadre là on donne la
possibilité à d'autres personnes de
venir dans la salle de concert et ils
vont ils vont découvrir quelque chose de
phénoménal avec la puissance qu'on leur
casse le poignet qui va avoir sur une
scène qu'est ce que ça apporte de
diriger de la musique dans ce jeu vidéo
c'était vraiment très très excitant je
dire parce que dans 1 c'était des
différentes compagnies de jeux vidéo
différents compositeurs extrêmement
talentueux et grand-sault teneur de 1
pauvre qu'on connaît pas nécessairement
non les faits mais ça permet d'être
humilié justement le fait que la musique
classique ou la musique symphonique elle
fait beaucoup plus partie notre vie
qu'on le pense
ce jeu contre l'oubli on pense toujours
à mon vieux faut vraiment connaître sur
pouvoir l'apprécier mais finalement les
guinéens se rendent bien compte que
qu'est-ce qui va faire en sorte qu'ils
vont jouer longtemps un jeu c'est parce
que il ya aussi cette énergie là qui est
dans le jeu entre la musique
d'exploration et la musique de combat
qui leur permet d'être encore plus dans
une activité merci
vidéo et dans ce concert le quai ce qui
est particulier c'était qu'on allait
aussi des des moments dans le concert
ont été carrément en interaction live
avec quelqu'un qui joue aux jeux vidéo
et donc je donnais des singles orchestre
pour qu'on peut changer en pleine visite
d'experts en zone de combat
donc si j'avais des premières qui s'est
vraiment donné les premiers jeux pendant
le match c'est vrai ici à montréal
les questions avaient mémorisé
l'allemand avec où les méchants vont
sortir et à quel moment donc ça va être
chaud voire assistant partir une musique
de combat en faisant un footing avec
m'hamed ma main gauche pin cet échange
est d'une portée à l'autre sur leur sol
leurs partitions et tout ça c'était des
idées vraiment génial par le compositeur
initiateurs de ce projet le maxximo les
apprentis hackers vous avez quand même
un parcours absolument exceptionnel j'ai
cru lire que pour vous devenir chef
d'orchestre schaeffer condé chef eux
aussi oui c'était comme devenir
astronome que pour moi c'est que le
métier d'astronaute on sait que cela
existe mais t'as aucune idée je n'ai
aucune idée très petite à savoir très
jeune à savoir quelles sont les étapes
qui vont amener à ce que tu puisses être
un jour j'aimerais être un jour
astronautes donc la même chose pour moi
un chef d'orchestre pour moi c'était
comme un métier oui existé mais de façon
très abstraite mais j'avais aucune idée
de comment je pouvais faire ce moment
donc c'est pour ça que quand je
rencontrais paolo bellomia en étant au
baccalauréat puis mode easy qui m'a même
proposé ce que tu avais déjà songé à
faire ce métier là on dit tout d'un coup
je me dis ah
donc ça veut dire que le prix en tenant
ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à présent et et
c'était le bon par contre que je peux ça
arriver là et bien entendu un grand
parcours ou à partir du moment où on
débute à étudier en direction
d'orchestre mais de savoir que tout ce
que j'avais fait auparavant été était
bon jeu c'était surprenant pour moi en
même temps une femme sur cette question
même on aimerait ne plus la poser la
question va que ce soit chef d'antenne
femmes puisque c'est le moche peut pas
ne pas vous la poser parce qu'on a
vraiment trop peu de femmes encore chef
d'orchestre escudé obstacles décembre
défi est ce que des préjugés
comment vous le voyez pas ce que vous
êtes un phénomène rare d'entendre
comment je le vois en fait c'est une
phase critique pour déterminer si des
moments qui ont fait en sorte que
c'était en raison vous fait que j'étais
une femme qui m'ont pénalisé par contre
je pense qu'on peut pas nier le fait que
tout le monde et nous inclus on peut
avoir on peut être victime d'un bien
conscient et par bien concierge par le
fait que au sein des orchestres
symphoniques
auparavant c'était seulement des hommes
et à partir du moment où on a commencé à
faire des auditions à l'aveuglent
derrière un rideau et qu'on essaie donc
aucune possibilité de savoir le genre de
le genre de la personne qui est en train
de jouer les triais d'orchestre
exclusivement par rapport à la
prestation musicale que les gens sont
maintenant sélectionner une scène et
orchestre
et bien c'est spécial parce que au bout
de quelques décennies on avait 50 % à 50
% d'hommes et femmes au sein des
orchestres ou du moins c'est à peu près
la saison de l'as et donc ça peut plus
montrer l'exemple du fait que quand on
ne peut pas le canton ne passe ce côté
visuel on doit peut-être donc
malheureusement on détecte une sélection
de biens concernent donc comme chef
d'orchestre bien entendu je dois être vu
par pour faire mon travail
on s'entend aussi que dans un métier où
la plupart des oeuvres que je dire ils
sont aussi
des compositeurs de européens et tout ça
donc on est quand même dans un dans un
dans un cadre qui kathleen je droit à
changer
heureusement ce que je vois par contre
ce que je de plus en plus de mes
collègues chefs d'orchestre commence à
avoir des postes de plus grande
envergure parce que c'est ça je pense
l'enjeu majeur des prochaines décennies
mais par contre je dois dire que quand
j'étais aux études ça me met fleuret
rarement l'esprit parce qu on était
trois femmes et deux hommes dans notre
classe de direction
donc je dirais que c'est plus dans les
médias que je sens que je sois sera par
le parent ou non au genre de question du
versement en entrevue donc à 35 en
direct de deux jours caisse a titré
chauffeur et d'un autre est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous voyez dans vingt ans
dans trentaine dont on développe pas au
fleuret j'imagine dans sa carrière on
explose mais dans vingt ans dans
cinquantaine même encore très jeune chef
à 35 parce qu'on peut vivre un exercice
la beauté de la chose on peut exercer
notre métier pendant de très longues et
des chars qui dirige même à 80 ans ben
oui parce que je me vois dans fait je me
vois vraiment faire exactement la même
chose que je fais présentement ça serait
peut-être avec d'autres orchestres mais
le plus important pour moi c'est
de voir que je capable de les toucher
les gens par les prestations musicales
sont offertes puisque je capable de
faire une petite différence dans les
communautés avec lesquelles je travaille
donc c'est surtout ça le plus important
et si je t'appelais à voyager davantage
mais ce sera bien vous l'avez fait vous
avez côtoyé des grands chefs en
avez-vous des chefs emblématiques
envahissent lyon mag à nous la donne
parce qu'on a gagné
certains cas d'échec qui m'ont
grandement inspiré je pense que déjà été
directeur musical de leurs que sa
famille de montréal et qui avait accepté
aussi que je le suive différents
endroits dans le monde pour voir cette
pétition
donc j'étais allé jusqu'à tel-aviv à
deux reprises pour voir ses répétitions
avec israël philharmonic orchestra
je suis vous citez répétition
d'allemagne donc ce stage circulent qui
m'ont grandement inscrits en dehors des
orchestres du québec ce soit lors qu'ils
s'impliquent leur place notre pôle
singles lors qu'est ce que vous rêveriez
de diriger au monde du jeu sans trop de
bruits
parce que c'est un privilège à chaque
fois qu'on est à plaindre avec un autre
acteur un compositeur au futur alors de
m'accepter
il y en aurait beaucoup mais je pense
que beethoven est resté un fort dans ma
vie
et pourquoi mais je pense que je peux
jamais me lasser aucune heure qui aucune
note qui prétend lui de ses oeuvres
tout est bien balancé tout et touchantes
ou des marques en jetons 6 est un
compositeur qui avait incarné une force
de caractère impressionnante
donc c'est pas comme ça les risques
d'isolement y avait trop de notes au nom
nord alors qu'elles ont reçues et
beethoven
le plus grand défi pour vous
au quotidien parce que c'est quoi le
plus grand défi c'est le fait que 95 %
de mon temps se passe à travers une
partition
à utiliser la partie s'est imaginé
chaque son est certain qu'à chaque fois
que je vais arriver devant un orchestre
en or qu'est ce que mes différents des
fois je vais travailler avec un
orchestre la première fois ça va être de
toujours d'avoir cette idée là est ce
que chaque plan chaque son cocktail que
je les imaginais vont bien se
concrétiser donc et toujours sets par
l'inconnue mais qu'il ya en même temps
il part existante dans le métier entre
le 95 % de préparation versus le 5 % qui
est finalement les répétitions tous les
confrères à quelqu'un que j'aimais aller
un concert qui ne vous connaît pas vous
a jamais vu qu'avez vous envie de lui
dire pour le goût de la musique
classique
je lui dirai en fait que cette personne
à connaître davantage la musique
classique elle de le penser parce que la
musique classique fait partie de leur
vie des fois les dans les publicités
dans les films dans les jeux vidéo on
peut dans tout et on n'a pas besoin de
connaître la musique classique pour pour
l apprécient parce que la musique c'est
une langage universel c'est la langue
des émotions et donc je pense que tout
le monde peut y trouver son compte en
écoutant consacrez vous et votre plus
grande émotion musicale avis ce serait
quoi oh mon dieu mes plus grandes
émotions
ah ben je pense que le moment qui était
le plus excitant pour moi jusqu'à
présent ça a été quand j'ai remplacé au
pied levé grand chef métro alain
altinoglu pour trois concerts avec
l'orchestré symphonique de montréal
donc il ne pouvait pas se présenter à
montréal et à quelques jours des
répétitions maestro kent nagano m'a
demandé est ce que tu serais prête à
prendre ses concerts là et je me dis que
si je refusais par crainte de ne pas
être assez préparés ou de nos pharmacies
de temps pour trouver un angle par
rapport aux interprétations des oeuvres
de regretter toute ma vie donc j'ai osé
j'ai dit oui j'ai partie des belles
nuits blanches
ça a été une expérience extrêmement
enrichissante avec l'hymne siècle où est
simple ça a été trois très beaux
concerts donc j'avoue que ces moments là
sont vraiment à mes mots et en terminant
le legs de kent nagano
à montréal mais pour vous sur mon dieu
pour moi ce serait au legs immense
récemment temps exceptionnel et
justement récemment il est venu même
leur casse a fini de l'estuaire encore
d'un autre 25e anniversaire et j'ai
trouvé que c'était drame extrêmement
généreux à lui et son épouse les
canisses numérique aux dames à devenir
dans cette belle région leur pouvoir
faire un concert puisque j'ai vraiment
apprécié qu'ils puissent être aussi
généreux avec lui c est de pouvoir
montrer aux musiciens de mon orchestre à
quel point cet homme là est enrichie
chaque à quel point mort pendant trois
années dans le cadre de 2,3 de trois
jours de répétition pour moi c'était
vraiment très touchant war in à gilbert
merci beaucoup à l'aller poursuivre
votre belle carrière auprès de très
nombreux orchestres au québec et
ailleurs dans le monde au plaisir de
vous retrouver très bientôt merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
mesdames messieurs au revoir et à la
pression
[Musique]